devin let's do a little background check
what's the credit score like bro
all right
okay what's your favorite flavor of
gatorade
all right riptide russia check it out
what kind of car are you driving
well a what
whoa whoa
hoity toity
is it a lease or do you own it
oh this guy's all right [ __ ]
i'm shoving up over here
this has got to be a classy question i
would assume it's very very not
is it garbage that the first time my
family tried sushi was because we had a
life insurance money after my dad died
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that does it
mercedes-benz huh
at 800 credit score ain't full of nobody
[ __ ]
this guy's driving ikea for sure
so your dad dies and you're like [ __ ] it
let's get sushi yeah
dad would have wanted us to go to
benihana i'm pretty sure
it's also like not the most expensive
food
you know
it's like you can get it at gas stations
now
i mean a california roll i feel like a
rich guy
clap it up for debit everybody let him
hear it that was [ __ ] awesome
[Applause]
he tuned a role in a riptide rush
that's what i'm talking about uh kevin w
yeah okay this is this is going to go
well yeah
that's our kind of people right there
yep here
it's probably on a next hill right now
[Laughter]
what'd you have for breakfast man
is that because you were fasting or
you're a dirt ball
okay
me too baby me too
hey me three what are we talking about
[Laughter]
what's your credit score looking like
not too shabby someone's gonna hit you
up for a loan after the show
hey who was the 780 guy
where's kevin at by the way
what kind of house you got you live in a
house with an apartment
oh boy
this is why we play the game ladies and
gentlemen
you can run but you can't [ __ ] hide
my parents basement does it have a
separate entrance for you to get down or
do you have to walk down through the
through inside the house
i gotta say hello
my mom charges me three kisses a day in
rent
i said i'll take the trash out later god
i don't have it on me i'm gonna pay you
at the end of the month i told you that
get off my [ __ ] back i'm not a union
guy
i don't have good benefits how old of a
fella are you
hey he could be in a regroup a
rebuilding phase you know what i mean
like a sports team what do we got
is it trash to go with your mother and
father to a strip club and then be the
one to pull your mom from going to the
atm for a third time
wow
somebody likes to experiment huh
that's a good landlord right there
that's me
[Music]
hot damn those atm fees at strip clubs
will clean you the [ __ ] out too you take
out 20 bucks cost you 48.
holy what was she getting was she
getting lap dances
hey
i can't blame her
holy [ __ ] what was your dad doing
jerking off
what i would be doing
trying to cancel his debit card that's
what he was doing
he was on the phone with citibank
whatever she tells you
i lost it two days ago
what was the name of the strip club
oh who's in key west
oh my god
what the [ __ ] the mecca of trash holy
[ __ ]
are your your parents big jimmy buffett
people by any chance
are they
what are you saying black sabbath
man i can't get a read on this [ __ ]
guy
i just know he's a dirtbag
black zap yes
she's requesting war pigs trying to get
[ __ ]
generals gathered in that message
i squeezed the tits and yesterday oh my
god
i had a jimmy buffett song ready to go
what do you want from me
[Applause]
i knew i had nothing to do so [ __ ] you
guys man the confidence for me to do it
was big i was like i hope i don't get
[ __ ] hung out to try on this and i
look over you're doing the second part
i was like this is bad i'm over here
doing the drum fill
i'm never gonna let you live that down
all right
uh yeah kev that's real trashy yeah
that's garbage man